so it's lovely theme music to that we
got on our channel but where are you
Jared plane I mean Jared plane to come
give me some uh some theme music jazz it
up if for no other reason than just to
annoy kamar that's that's a good enough
reason I know I know Jared and comer
have a little little feud going on the
internet so hopefully I can get the the
jazzy hook up tonight we're going to go
over an opening that was requested it's
been requested for four months now the
last person I saw requested this was a
war Kid 42 he wants to see the brayer so
we're going to go over the reuleaux Pez
tonight it's already been requested by
the only person in the audience here
that we do a d4 opening next week and
we're going to be going over the brayer
tonight so we'll have a good look at the
the Rui Lopez so after a 45 Knight f3
knight c6 Bishop b5 we get one of the
the oldest and most popular openings of
all time and by far the main move here
is a 6 though Knight f6 the Berlin
defense also is very popular especially
at the top level right now and sort of
the point of the Ray Lopez you know
there's other options you could also put
your bishop on c4 that seems like a nice
diagonal but on b5 we have some certain
pressure indirectly on the center
because sometimes we're taking this
Knight and grabbing this pawn however
due to some tricks we have it's not an
immediate threat so for example after a
6 if we play the exchange variation
which is you know it's a fine way to
play standing with chuka recommended so
he likes to to try this variation and
here white should just castle and then
black decides what he should do about is
epon but let's go ahead and just make
sure we remember this trick what do we
play here Queen d4 forking the pawn at
night which isn't very promising for
white so after the knight retreats you
can take the pawn
and you guys think there's only two
legal moves but I get another chance to
make the joke that happened in our
Knights tournament here and our weekly
Knights tournament
what move was played in that game
castles yeah so this this is one of our
games and just for Bensimon he left the
room but well he likes to hear it let's
crank it up a little bit he likes to
hear the illegal moves which is a very
good move and then yeah then rook e1
came next move and white went pretty
quickly okay so the more popular move is
is to block because you realize you're
in check but this isn't very good for
white after some trades and Bishop g4
black is ready to castle for example
after rook e1 castles maybe d3 is your
best chance here but okay most people
play King to f1 and you can just take
and you can already see Black has lots
of activity the better pawn structure
and this I mean this is just good for
black so this is not the right way to
play the exchange variation but uh okay
that's not our main focus tonight after
a six since okay the real there really
is no threat to take the knight
immediately but hopefully in the future
if we just keep our Bishop on the same
diagonal as the knight it'll be a
recurring theme so we have to constantly
in the very first few moves here always
be calculating what happens if we take
the knight and now we'll look at the
main move Knight to f6 attacking the e
pawn and here there's sort of a decision
that already needs to be made by white
and I think this applies a lot to
tournament players the main move here is
to castle which leads to sort of the
most ambitious plans by white but
there's also the move d3 which is
practical for tournament players because
it cuts out so many possible variations
that black can play but that being said
it's not as ambitious as castling
because in the main lines normally we
play C six and we want to play d4 and
get the big pond center but you know
there's a lot of players out there that
just prefer the d3 move because it okay
you cut out like so much theory huge
unless you're the plan in because in the
other body is an extra movement before
and yet you still will you still will
play for d4 you're going to do it a
little bit slower Brant black yeah which
is the main move yeah a five okay and
this is a little bit premature because
you're dropping this pond so there are
sometimes some gambits where you can
gambit your e pond but in general what
happens is he waits until that pond is
protected and now this is a real serious
threat because if Black gets to play
Knight to a5 and take the bishop it's
already been a strategic disaster for
white instead whenever they are actually
threatening to put their knight on 85 so
whenever they protect their epon you
want to be able to play the move c3 that
way ninety five doesn't have any real
sting to it because you play Bishop c2
and so here would just be sort of the
main starting position for the d3 line
which will be kind of similar to
tonight's lecture so even if you're
going to go back and you want to play d3
in these positions just I mean watching
some of the lectures of the more popular
lines also will give you some clues as
to how you should still develop your
pieces and one day we might still play
d4 here as white and it's going to be a
slow manoeuvring game both sides have an
equal share of the center so it's
nothing terribly special but I think so
I'd prefer white very very slightly and
open I mean Carlson has played d3 before
he's played both moves so you're in
pretty good company either way but
tonight we're focused on the main move
which is to Castle okay and now Bishop
to e7 and in some lines you can bring
your Bishop all the way out to c5 which
sort of is sort of the natural thing
when you're first starting you like you
don't you want to get your Bishop
outside of the pawn chain now you're
gonna play d6 and the bishop is going to
be trapped in but that's actually fine
in these variations normally it's white
that's going to do a King side attack so
Bishop e7 keeps the bishop pretty close
to home and in the very early stages
it lets us go into some lines where if
we take here and white swings and rook
over we're shielding the e-file so
certain variations this helps us out but
now it's White's turn and here he
typically defends this pawn with the
move rook to e1 and that might also seem
a little strange if you're unfamiliar
with the position I mean why move in a
rook shouldn't you get a night out and
to get your bishops out but he is
waiting because he's going to do the roy
lopez maneuver in the future and the
real lopez is all about maneuvering but
what do I mean when I say the Rui Lopez
maneuver okay and that is what I'm
talking about
but we're going to put a pawn on c3 in
the future like really soon because you
know they're going to protect their play
d6 and then you know they're going to do
this and they're going to try to trap
our Bishop here so if you put a knight
on c3 sometimes which seems like the
most logical move are you put your
knight in the most logical spot it
actually does prevent you from saving
your bishop in the future so more common
is to play C 3 and either d3 or d4 and
it is you got to the right square but
normally you go through d2 yeah you read
it once upon a time yeah that's the key
maneuver that you really need to know if
you play the Roy Lopez that just occurs
in every single game ok so now the pawn
is protected which means white has a
threat white is threatening to take on
c6 and then take on e5 that's the threat
so you got to do something about it so
black plays b5 and surprisingly in the
database people have played moves other
than this one it's very strange
they those games didn't last very long
they weren't very high rated players
either but ok so b5 it's a move that's
both good and bad just like every other
move in chess obviously you get a lot of
space on the Queen side which is very
good but the the one downside is in the
future it'll be white they might be able
to open the a file whenever he's good
and ready but ok b5 it's it's very
typical in these lines nothing wrong
with it
and now there's already a choice you can
play d6
which is what we're going to be looking
at is the clue closed roy lopez that's
what we're looking at tonight but i do
want to mention the possibility of
castling which can lead to the marshall
gambit so here by not putting the pawn
on d6 we're preserving the ability to
play d5 in the future and pretty soon we
should do the Marshall gambit I prepared
it once but then like I guess we weren't
filming or something so I didn't show
that that lecture yet but it's one I do
intend to do in the future so you know
request the Marshall gambit maybe you'll
get it and there's all sorts of anti
Marshalls you know a 4-h 3 but if you
play c3 you do need to know all about
this gambit here and the point is you
give up a pond but black is intending to
get lots of pressure the bishop comes
here this bishops here this Queen is
here this rook comes over let's draw as
many scary arrows as we can the pawn
advances this rook comes in let's draw
as many scary arrows as possible so
black
you know his goal is to get tons of
pressure to a you know foot for the pawn
so it is it's kind of nice because at
the top level that's it's interesting to
watch these games you know because they
they like some people like to grab pawns
and prove that they their upon up so
it's all about defense and attack and
balancing them both so very exciting
stuff will be covered pretty soon and
obviously also in this variation if in
this position you play d6 you just
transpose to what we're doing now but
it's you know it's kind of kind of nice
even be kind of bluffin like oh maybe
I'm maybe I'm playing the marshal maybe
I'm not so if you like to Bluff you can
castle there but okay so the main move
is d6 either now or after castling
and now the e5 pawn is protected so we
want to make sure we understand what
that means it means we're going to go
win that Bishop so hopefully you know a
move we have to play here the move c3 so
after 95 we can just drop back okay and
after castles where we're very close to
the mainline here and in this position
White's intention is to play the move d4
and then that's how he's going to get a
slight advantage she's going to have two
pawns right in the center
compared to blacks one he's going to
have a little bit more space there
however this is usually prefaced
prefaced with a move H three and the
reason is if you immediately play the
move d4 which has been played by you
know very decent grandmasters so it's
not impossible you do allow blacks um
counter play after Bishop to g4 so
you're threatening the piece that's
protecting d4 so already you have to
sort of do something about that tension
in the center so you can play Bishop e3
d5 also is a close second but okay for
example after taking which we'll look at
but I'd you like to blunder here usually
I like to blender in this position just
to see if people are alert here what
would white play in this position yeah
Bishop d5 forking both the Knights oops
yeah
it's a good good blunder to know about
so instead they take in the center and
after ninety five there's two lime so I
mean then I can go to c4 you can play C
five and in either case white does get
some counter play so I'm sorry black get
some counter play which is one reason
why they they restrict this in most
cases h3 and it's sort of a part two of
the the general spirit of the Royal
Lopez
it is white you know wants a very very
slight advantage he wants to squeeze he
wants to grind and you know you play h3
and then that just stops what they're
trying to do and you'll play d4 next
move so here there's a major branch we
already looked at the chigorin in the
past so that's been covered but there's
actually I mean there's so many moves
here and hopefully we get to cover them
all in the future I mean there's the
Zaitsev there's the Caray's there's all
sorts of move like everything everything
is a move here but tonight we're going
to be looking at the brayer which begins
with this mysterious Knight retreat
Knight to b8 so here we have the very
starting point of what we can call the
brayer
now why would you go there I mean you
could go to 85 gained a tempo on the
bishop but if you go back to b8 blacks
point is after the move d4 he wants to
play Knight B to d7 and he's just
solidifying the center
he's got good control now the knight is
is quite useful on d7 and he fulfilled
his job on c6 so you maneuver the knight
and this is one of the most solid and
safest ways to play the Roy Lopez so
it's very popular and you know Carlson
has played both sides of this dozen
times so a very good way
very good safe way to play no matter
what your your level is and we'll
discuss now the the basic themes here
White's plan is okay hopefully a little
bit more obvious than blacks because you
know he's going to do the Roy Lopez
maneuver the knight is going to whoop
it's not going that far the Knights
going to g3 where he's looking in at
some of these like squares often they'll
be sacrifices on f5 so that's sort of
his plan at some point I guess maybe
leave us on the board at some point he's
going to play the move a for perhaps if
all the pieces are out of the way he can
even double on the a file which will
kind of see today and what is black's
main plan well one for one thing we're
going to get some pressure on the center
and in anticipation of a knight going to
g3 we're going to want to play the move
g6 which completely restricts the knight
but it also means we need to kind of
maneuver our pieces so it's a lot of
slow subtle maneuvers early on in these
games and if we're probably g6 we want
to put our Bishop on g7 so Brook e8 you
know Bishop f8 Bishop g7 these sorts of
moves should be played okay
and we'll look at a game now so this
game I like to show games that were
played you know very recently this is a
game that was played just in the US
Chess Championship so it's still very
topical and this is the game between
Wesley so and gotta calm Sookie and it
was the very very first round and all
three of the the top players the top 10
players in the world they all started
really well they all won games pretty
quickly which is sort of surprising I
mean you expect them to win lots of
games but the l1 relatively easily I
mean it's they played a lot harder games
going forward and I mean God I had said
to in the press conference he's like you
know I'm jet-lagged he just he just
played sort of a poor game and I mean
Wesley just made it look easy that's
what he those so they both continued
with their normal maneuvers the night
goes to d2 it's going to f1 and now you
know you you're considering one of these
two moves does a short amove to consider
and that the best option here is to play
Bishop to b7 a little bit of prophylaxis
if you don't know what that means come
tomorrow night we'll have a little
lecture about it
so you're preventing Knight to f1
because you're attacking e4 twice so
white needs to find a way to protect it
again
Bishop c2 and now after some normal
maneuvers we can see the the standard
position and here we have sort of the
starting position
so the basic middle game plans have been
accomplished by both players and after
g6 preventing the knight from
infiltrating the most common move here
is a four but that wasn't played in the
game instead in the game it was Bishop
to g5 so we'll come right back to that
but after a four we'll just show the
main line in this position the move c5
is the most common makes a lot of sense
and just to illustrate one thing and
we'll see it a couple times tonight if
you just play a general move Bishop g7
you know it's just sort of a normal move
White has this interesting idea that you
should be aware of if you play this
variation and that is to play Bishop to
d3
and you attack the beep on a second time
to force black to play a move like c6
which is very possible it's a very solid
way to play and we'll even take a quick
glimpse at a Carlson game where he
played this rather voluntarily and okay
we'll see calm ski played this tonight
but it is sort of annoying and in
general you want to get your your C pawn
out if you want to achieve the typical
Braer structure which is this one so you
put we're going to be able to play c4
and that gives you an excellent square
for your knight and then you know when
you're on c5 you're also attacking efore
again you're putting some pressure in
the center this is the typical way to
play and white generally plays Bishop to
g5 which provokes h6 white is eventually
going to start an attack on the kingside
so he's hoping to provoke h6 if you
don't play h6 immediately then okay we
play Queen to d2 and we can consider
doubling our rooks and eventually
opening up the a file and this is
possible that can allow this
but most people prevent it when the
bishop drops back they plug their knight
in just to go a little bit farther so we
get a general idea of where the pieces
are going in this opening we attack the
H pawn and after it moves we can go
right back into g5 okay we break the pin
and now it moves like rook to a3 which
you know may surprise you if you're new
to this variation but it's very typical
to double the rooks here it's kind of
like the example we saw in the improving
your pieces lecture where you you double
on a file before you take the pawn so
this is the main main main line and the
theory continues it goes on forever and
ever and ever so but I think this is a
good place to stop and go back and look
at the game here so not the immediate a4
but Bishop to g5 which is not nearly as
popular but based off this game I think
it's a very reasonable way for white to
play so if you don't play h6 I play
Queen d2
come ski decided to play h6 and now you
need to retreat your Bishop if you go to
e3 which seems like the most sensible
square black can take on d4 and then
there's a discovered attack on your epon
so that would cost you a pond you could
go back to c1 but then you're in the way
of the rooks so it's hard to double on
the a file if your rook is blocked in by
a bishop so in the game he went back to
d2 okay and black just continued
normally and now a4 so again the most
popular move here is c5 which wasn't
played in the game and just to give you
a general look I mean we achieve this
structure again and our knight goes here
and it's very solid both sides have the
chances you have a little bit more space
on the Queen side they're going to think
about attacking you similar to the way
that we see in the main game but in this
position Tomsky decided to play the move
c6 quite solid but a little passive and
okay I think at this point was Lee so he
was getting his little super grandmaster
tingling in his fingers okay he's played
one little you know passive move little
inaccurately even though it's it's
probably playable so I mean it's I
wouldn't say that this move you know
cost him the game
but things all of a sudden just
immediately start going pretty bad here
for black white just goes in for an
attack and it just worked so wisely very
strong attacker and I mean where where's
the attack it doesn't look like you have
anything look at all the pieces around
the black King how are you going to get
there well he started by taking on b5
and after we took back he took on a
eight so he's distracting the Queen away
from the King side and there's one
square in particular you always want to
be watching and that's the square f5
white wants to put a knight there
even if it's a sacrifice so he played
Knight to h4 and he's thinking about
sacrificing he has these sort of ideas
one of the Knights is going to jump here
the Queen can go here this is very very
common and ok so he decides let's get
the Queen back you remember this game
mm-hmm
all right good yeah we'll try not to
spoil too much of it for the for the
good audience at home they haven't seen
it so very good so I'll call on you and
I need all the right answers ok yeah all
right so the Queen eyeballing the knight
on h4 now he attacks the h-bomb and in
the game he sort of miscalculated he
played Queen to h7 which is not a very
good move now I mean the TAC is is
coming really quick but it's based on a
miscalculation instead if you play a
move like 9 h7 for instance so you're
attacking my knight you could go back to
f3 but if I know Wesley and I know him
pretty well
because he was on our US chess league
team and I was a TD for that for for a
couple years he was going to play Knight
to f5 and alright I mean you could
probably better take it otherwise I'm
taking on h6 or I'm taking your Bishop
and then taking on h6 and if you take
what is going to happen is you're going
to end up getting a couple people pawns
here you get two pawns for your piece
and you know something like this and the
King can go away and white certainly has
lots of compensation I would prefer to
be white here it's it's a lot easier and
the black King doesn't have shelter but
ok it is it is a piece so black has you
know every right to think that he has a
good chance of surviving here so this
perhaps would have been played but
didn't get in the game the inferior King
to h7 and what did Wesley do
9f5 okay so he took yeah all right now
we're on your each pond and come ski
thought he had this defense which is
sort of typical in these attacking lines
notice to I am attacking d6 and it's
sort of typical would be a lot better
this night where somewhere you know
either either location over here where
the rook would truly be able to swing
over and protect everything on the six
rink but here now we grab a pond so that
the very typical attack here you get the
two ponds for the piece and a very nice
night on f5 and notice that taking with
the bishop is impossible because of
Bishop h6 queen h6 King g8 Queen g7
checkmate also I'm just attacking your
bishops you better protect it or move it
so he protects it now the bishops
protected we are thinking now about
taking on h6 cuz we got the rook on e6
now so alright I just go back and yeah
okay okay so he's he said alright you
want to trade and this he just clearly
miscalculated something here so we'll
pause for just a second and one thing
that should be mentioned is the
possibility of this bishop it may not
look like it but now d5 is a threaten a
lot of these positions and then okay if
you take my bishop just comes into the
game so I don't know what he was
expecting here but do you remember what
was played in this game or can you
figure it out Bishop takes f6 this is
what was played
and again you can't take with either
night because of Queen h6 so you can't
take either way you got to take either
with the rook or the Queen and they're
they're both bad news for the similar
reason in the game he took with the
Queen and now what did white play d5 d5
excellent so uh alright he's he's saying
if you want to take and the brave
computer likes to take this so if your
computer they take this you know even
though this is like super scary but it
recognizes that it's lost so it wants
you to like do this and allow this check
and then you pick up the Bishop on d5
and it's like yeah I know I'm lost but
that's that's the best which is a really
bad sign in the game okay a human might
not want to lose his his stuff and you
know me he just thought you know the
knight would take the rook here which
which was just a mistake cuz what did he
play it's already been yeah g4 and I
mean the threat is g5 removing the
defender of the rook and white will win
material here and there's just nothing
that can be done about it so brutal
stuff you just this attack just sort of
came straight out of nowhere you know
you play one little wrong move you play
c6 you know it also didn't help that is
his king went to h7 and it was really
tough on him you if you've seen the
video of him he was he was in pain you
know he was very sad about this game he
just when g4 happened here I mean he
just said it was just a human in a lot
of pain so very tough you know it was
his first first round he got off to a
slow start he did okay just a little bit
worse than then you would expect from
him in a normal tournament he just he
didn't get off to a good start but
halfway through he he picked it up a
little bit he you recovered some okay so
that's the dream for white you attack
you know you win but if you clicked on a
Braer lecture on the internet you might
want to know how to play it as black
that's possible
and there's no reason you know not to
show a game from blacks point of view so
I'll flip the board around and this is
the game between Alexander Mistah who's
a 2600 GM versus a nice giri so this was
played in the Qatar Masters in 2014 and
we're going to see in this game it's
just an example of a super Grandmaster
just outmaneuvering a regular
Grandmaster only 2600 so we'll get back
to the Roy Lopes we're looking at the a6
lines and we're looking at castles there
should be seven and now that the pawn is
protected we need to play b5 the bishop
goes back we can castle or play d6 d6
was chosen in the game so I'm not even
gonna pretend like I'm playing the
marshal I'm playing the closed where he
Lopes so I was threatening to you know
just go get your Bishop with 95 castles
h3 and your next move is is obviously
going to be d4 so Knight to b8 the
brayer ok d4 Knight B to d7 and again we
have the the typical starting point for
this variation White's going to maneuver
his Knight to g3 black is going to first
make him retreat his Bishop and then
he's going to do his maneuver which was
played in the game so this was the game
well we'll come right back to this but
it is worth noting here too there is
this possible move which is not as
popular but in the highest-rated game in
which the brayer was played the game was
Sergey Karjakin versus Magnus Carlsen
from Norway 2013 and this position arose
so it's it's worth just taking a quick
glimpse at this game when we'll go over
the whole thing and yeah this is yeah
this is where he in just a second he
allowed you know white to play this
variation with Bishop to d3 and he
played c6
so again more popular in this position
is C 5 and F equals the center C 4 and
the night goes to C 5 but yeah in the
game it was an interesting choice by
Mike Carlson in this position he just
played Bishop to f8 and okay after this
he was a little passive and was kind of
interesting about this tournament it's
the khari Aachen started with you know a
wildly great start he had like three out
of four or four out of five you know he
started off really really well on this
tournament and now you're playing Magnus
and he achieved a very nice position
rook c8 it wasn't the most common move I
know at the time all the commentators
were like rook c8 and you know you
instead g6 or Queen c7 were the more
popular moves and you get such a
position and okay really nice play by
Sergei and you got a position where he
was just better it was funny too in the
press conference
his Carlson was in this position he's
like yeah if what just doesn't do
anything then it should be really easy
draw but White is slightly better he's
having a fantastic tournament he went
for the win and that cost him so he got
the better position but at the end of
the day the big secret is be higher
rated than your opponent you know it
matters more than if you're you're
better or worse the trick is to be
higher rated okay which is what's going
to happen in this game onigiri higher
rated so he wins okay so in this game
we'll look at the the more normal move
this is still the main main line and you
go there and I play g6
okay now a4
do you think onigiri played some like
Bishop g7 allowing Bishop d3 now he
played c5 so you play c5 and after they
lock it up he plays d4 okay so this is
sort of a very typical game it's just a
model game of how you should play with
the black pieces and my just my
immediate regrouping I'm putting my
knight here my bishop goes here okay I
don't know what I'm doing in the next
couple moves here so when the bishop
goes to g5 if we don't play h6 then
you'll play Queen to d2
what ask URI shows it is possible to
allow this
okay the Queen goes to d2 white now is
thinking about doubling on the a file
and in general you put your Bishop on e7
you know threatening to move away and
train stuff and white doesn't want to
train in these lines so he moved his
Bishop out of the way he doesn't want to
trade because he's gonna launch an
attack at some point so he needs all of
his pieces now if this was a super super
grandmaster tournament I would expect
Knight f8 and people and the audience
already see what's coming you know and
then draw but okay Gary's 160 some
points higher rated than his opponent at
the time of this game so after this he
decides okay I'll maneuver and sometimes
black is thinking about f5 f5 is on the
agenda as well as I mean occasionally
white also wants to play f4 but I am
thinking about playing a5 I might do it
now I might do it a little bit later and
here white just makes a big mistake
a5 and when you show this to the
computer it's like yes zero zero zero
zero but this is actually a pretty big
strategic mistake closing down the Queen
side much better was doubling on the a
file and then opening the a file but
it's not easy I mean if you've I mean
what what could possibly be wrong here
and we're going to see it where you're
going to see a 2700 just play super
strong moves now and this is a great
planning exercise you may want
pause your video at home let the
audience decide the pawn on a5 is
actually quite weak and then he's going
to take back the pawn but we'll give you
a chance how would you reconfigure all
of your pieces here which if you play
the Rui Lopez you have to maneuver so
here's a good test mm-hmm which he did
yeah the night went to b7 which means
the bishop is going to c8 it's much
better diagonal now that there's a pawn
on d5 so that all happened and then yeah
he's attacking the pawn so he played
Bishop c8 okay and he's going to double
in anticipation of this so that is one
way to protect your pawn and now how
else where else you can put your pieces
so you can win that pon c5 yeah I like
c5 Knight c5 very good which okay well
we'll go we'll go this far but now what
is the plan for black how how do you
plan on rounding up this pawn so somehow
yeah move all these pieces around to
your Bishop is here so in the game he
has the interesting idea of Bishop d7
with the idea Knight to a4 so yeah so he
blocks on the a file and then he can
take the pawn so that's going to happen
so it's very interesting maneuvering
these are the type of slow maneuvers you
can get into when the center is closed
so we Lopez players kind of you need if
you can outmaneuver your opponent you
can win lots of games okay so he went
back which is typical the knight might
go to g4 he might play f4 after Bishop
to d7 he's ready to play Knight to a4
and white dropped back his bishop now I
think
he was planning on in some lines
dropping the bishop in to be sex to
protect the pond and we'll have a look
at that when it happens but here he
played a super grand master move a move
I don't think a lot of people would ever
consider in this position so you can
pause your video see if you can play
like Geary here I think almost everybody
you know it just grabbed their knight
put it on a four but a very nice move
Bishop to h4 just out I just you know
want take your your knight and if you
just completely pass let me just make a
wasted move I mean there's no reason to
do that
what was the was a threat f5 yeah this
is the positional threat and if you take
I take your knight and it's it's worth
you know considering to take this pawn
but it really shouldn't be enough it's
worth considering you can either take
the night you can play Bishop h4 and
it's a piece you know the computers like
it's okay but but it's not very good and
the other option is to take here and we
take back with the bishop and black is
better so yeah very very interesting
idea and you know if you don't waste a
move let's not waste a move here he
played Knight to f3
well again you put the knight in the way
so now you can drop back you stop that
f6 this time and if you don't get your
Knights out of the way it's it's kind of
hard for you to like go directly attack
me you know somehow you need to like
push your pawns is what he's going to
try to do later on in the game and I'm
kind of surprised he didn't just play
Knight to h2 here again just to say it
you want to repeat that's that's one of
me and I'm sure gearing would have tried
something else and I do like just how
patient he was okay the night went back
we'll see some real real patient play by
Gary make sure everything is right
before he plays Knight day 4 so I assume
at home everybody's trying to play
Knight a for every move here but but
just just wait the knight goes to e2
he's thinking about g4 Knight g3 he has
to do something aggressive over on the
Kings side
okay you're gonna lose upon on the
queenside but maybe we can get an attack
going that's how you have to be thinking
here as white in another very very
strong patient move Queen to c8 this is
almost a threat it almost works but it's
not a threat now but it could be in some
other situations if you take immediately
on h3 if we give black another move well
it's hard to get a third attacker into
the game so it's it doesn't work quite
yet but also on c8 we're protecting the
c4 pawn so we can imagine our knight
going to a4 and the bishop takes so
we're going to have to double our ponds
but on c8 now we're protecting the C
pond so he's making sure everybody is is
working just right before we we go in
for that and prophylactically white went
to h2 so we're going to play g4 Knight
g3 and okay patience
G for now White's getting serious so
Gary gets serious now is the time
alright so he took he took back and now
a very interesting scenario occurs and
he was waiting for G 4G for mates this
idea a little bit better for black is
finally the time and we're going to see
why now
perhaps okay and the game night 2 G 3
was played and briefly we'll just
mention that this also was a possibility
the computer wanted to do just sack the
exchange but yeah I hate being an
exchange down against Gary I hate when
that happens
so you could consider defending this way
but I think and gear is pretty good when
he's up in exchange but the move that's
most interesting is well what happens on
a Bishop to b6 you know protect the pond
well here there's actually a tactical
possibility but it might work out for
white in the end so there's a little
counter tactic what is the the tactical
move here in this position yeah you can
take the pawn what's this about as he
said Queen c5 double attack okay and
first let's make a mistake which is
easier than finding the right move is
white
so first let's make a mistake okay you
attack my bishop I move it and I would
like to go over this you see this move
and you you kind of instantly know black
is winning because okay minimum I'm
getting this Knight back but it is an
interesting attack it's it's worth
showing the finish here just because it
it's just it's a really pretty way that
black in this position so again you may
want to pause at home if you don't want
me to spoil it but I'm just going to
give the the answer away right here
black could continue with a 5
the audience is confused you take on d6
I play rock a6 and the rack yeah the
rook is swinging over so let's say you
don't want to lose your piece fair
enough
now another shocker
Bishop takes G for opening the H file
also threatening a knight so we take g5
this is the idea the rook swings over to
h6 alright we're not done yet
d6 shut you down but I have two rooks so
things work out for me and the threat of
route to h6 is terminal you can you know
sack on g5 and then give your Queen away
you know I play work h6 that's possible
but okay this is just winning so it was
a very interesting attacking idea I
don't know if perhaps he saw at least a
little bit of it I mean if you just see
this position just seeing this position
on the board and you think oh okay I
mean he's at least getting his piece
back he's also taken I have to you get a
little scared but white actually has a
move here that is fine you can he can
save himself here a little counter
tactic and I'm uh I'm going to give it
away so in this position 92t for one
point is if you take with your epon I
take back with my C pawn and I'm
protecting my bishop if you take here I
can play among other mopes my just c6
and this is this is quite reasonable I
think you know had it been a position
like this if this had arisen in the game
he would say okay this is sort of much
better than my position was a moment ago
the white king is is obviously not as
safe as the black King but considering
the way the game went I'm sure he'd
rather have this mental game than the
one that occurred in the game it's an
interesting counter tactic there it was
I don't know if it was missed or if he
saw it or not but in the game he played
Knight to g3 which is actually a mistake
now we're just up upon this is this was
just a pond
okay the rook comes over the G file you
have to do something you have to get an
attack going if you don't attack me I
mean I'm just up a pond and up a nice
giri which helps okay all right gang a
temple on the Queen improve our pieces
and here he goes
hopefully we're looking at this this f5
square and there are a lot of ways black
can go wrong in this position but again
prophylaxis we're anticipating a knight
going to f5 and if we take back with our
Jeep on he can open the G file you can
take back with this other night there's
a lot of bad stuff that can happen so he
played King h8 I'm just getting off the
G file now if you sack a knight I can
take and I have some more time to defend
so in the game he went here because he
thinks he has a threat but it doesn't
work out for him so Queen f3 Queen f3
thinks he has a threat thinks he has a
threat yeah what are they 11 well Devi
walked in the room so everybody's
laughing and thanks for joining us Danny
he thinks he has a threat here so we see
Queen d8 similar to the makovski game we
attacked the knight on h4 and white
thinks he's being tricky here he thinks
he's clever he takes on f7 which is a
blunder he obviously must have seen this
move that's no surprise to anybody but
what did he think he had as a trick it
doesn't work but what does he think the
trick is
yeah Knight takes g6 but this is just a
piece and then the game didn't last much
longer
well you're threatening d6 but okay I
don't know what he saw when he went in
for this variation and the best he could
do here is Queen to g5 but let's just
show the finish he went to e6 which is
much worse and his Queen got trapped
so it seemed here like once he was down
upon he sort of just went all-in and
went a little bit too nuts and he lost
immediately so that's that's what tends
to happen at all sorts of levels you
know when you're down just a little bit
of material you tend to freak out
because it's you don't want to sit there
all day upon down you may be as a busy
man but just to show an example of what
would happen if sorry if we play Queen
to g5 it also seems quite reasonable but
here we can do a combination of taking
on g5 and taking on f2 the most pleasing
perhaps is the take on f2 first you
can't take with the bishop because
you're you need to protect your queen so
ok say you block now hopefully the first
move you calculate is rook takes rook
check so I can shock you a little bit
just a little bit and now we can take
here and we're up a piece for example we
can attack your beep on you protect it
Bishop f8
just preventing Bishop e7 and we're a
piece up so I mean that was no better
than trapping your queen but okay here
you could fight but you know at the at
the Grandmaster level this is this is
not much of a game anymore so we saw two
very interesting games we saw a model
attacking game by white we saw you know
model maneuvering game as black so
hopefully that inspires you a little bit
maybe you want to check out the brayer
and you know if you liked it hit a hit
like share subscribe and we'll get the
the last round in here of Monday night
mayhem so let's let's do it